leonardo da vinci lo conoscete tutti
sicuramente il più grande genio mai
esistito un extra terra
c'è chi dice che arriva da marte ne
hanno scritti quanti libri sono 200 anni
che scrivo libri su leonardo vinci e noi
siamo orgogliosi perché in italiano come
noi non mi sto raccontare le cose che
potete trovare sui libri ce ne sono fin
troppi
vi racconto delle cose un po strane
allora questo lo conoscete tutti l'ha
fatto lui l'uomo con cui lo chiamano
l'uomo con quattro gambe e quattro mani
cosa ha inventato provate a immaginare
un libro lo avrete sicuramente visto
avrete visto una mostra come da bambino
mi sono appassionato condotta vedere
mostre musei sono rimasto sconvolto da
quante cose ha inventato lo vediamo qua
la bicicletta la catapulta quella fare
giratina sull'acqua da sola girando una
manovella lo scoop a device il
paracadute il carro armato tutto ha
inventato cos'ha inventato tutto
praticamente cosa manca nel macchine
volanti al resto ne siamo sicuri ne
siete sicuri in tasca avete un euro vero
nell'euro c'è l'uomo con quattro mani
quattro gambe ma come si chiama quel
disegno lo sapete tutti si chiama uomo
vitruviano usate per una volta ogni
tanto non credete arresto usate il
vostro cervello uomo vitruviano vuol
dire che è stato fatto da vitruvio
leonardo lo ha copiato e tutto il resto
tutto il resto lo ha copiato
è brutto e triste fa venire ma come cosa
mi sta raccontando questa persona
eppure se voi andate a guardare i
documenti storici
vi do dei suggerimenti andati secca su
wikipedia dire militari francesco di
giorgio tacco la gente sconosciuta libri
medievali chissà che roba non voglio
neanche guardarli eppure in quei libri
prima di leonardo
tutte queste macchine sono presenti
eccole qua catapulta macchine da guerra
tutte tutte tutte le macchine che io da
bambino credevo forse lo stato inventato
e leonardo alla fine ho scoperto
studiando dopo anni che hanno tutte
copiate da chi dai suoi maestri dei suoi
ingegneri da ma pensate al carro
falciante ma ce l'aveva già gli antichi
romani ce l'avevano il film ben hur
vi ricordate stessa cosa eppure eppure
ci hanno raccontato che lo nardo al più
grande genio del mondo perché ha fatto
queste cose e sconvolgente ma è la
verità storica non vi sto raccontando
delle frottole andate a cercare per
favore
stasera qualche informazione questi sono
i libri medievale su quello nardò
studiava la storia lunghissima non me la
sto a raccontare ma sicuramente
conoscete il codice atlantico e se vi
dicessi che non è di leonardo c'è
scritto sul frontespizio il codice
atlantiche di pompeo leoni che ha
raccolto più di 1200 fogli di leonardo
in questi manoscritti ci sono
sicuramente delle cose incredibili
meravigliose ma gli abiti e mai visti
oltre ai 20 30 disegni che tutti quanti
conosciamo del carro armato che ci fanno
vedere sempre gli stessi libica sono
sempre gli stessi fotocopie dei
fotocopie come le mostre e gli altri gli
altri mille documenti gli altri 5.990
documenti dove sono perché oggi ne
abbiamo 6.000 di pagine web
probabilmente lui ne avrà fatti che
anche il doppio sono state perdute 6.000
ne abbiamo contate dove sono ci sono il
mio lavoro io chiamo una cosa
affascinante lo chiamo archeologia
vinciana multimediale perché io vado a
scoprire i manoscritti e gli altri 5.900
manoscritti dove ha scoperto il verona
perché quello che avete visto anche voi
andate via documentare è il copione e
leonardo
in realtà gli altri documenti sono una
specie di matrice quasi a internet
multimedia worldwide nella testa di
leonardo perché tutti i documenti sono
collegati tra di loro gli indizi per
costruire le nuove macchine che faccio
da anni sono sparpagliati in questi
documenti il problema cos'è che tutti
questi documenti sono brutti come questo
questa non è la gioconda tutti quanti
alla gioconda l'ultima cena meraviglioso
io ho scoperto che il vero leonardo ai
veri segreti altro che gioconda sono qui
dentro in un solo foglio di cui 6.000 ci
sono tante piccole cose qua dentro ci
sono 50 soggetti esplosi che leonardo
avete visto non è presentato bene perché
il trucco cosa era che leonardo si
vendeva come ingegnere militare per
guadagnare soldi è brutto ma è la verità
per diventare famose per guadagnare
soldi lui si è venduto al duca di milano
promettendogli di essere un ingegnere
militare non si è presentato come
pittore mi racconta un sacco di frottole
alcuni documentari e tutto documentato
ma lui era ignorante in campo militare
perché perché da bambino aveva studiato
al bellocchio aveva imparato a disegnare
dalla mattina alla sera e che cosa fa un
bambino per imparare a disegnare dalla
mattina alla sera al verrocchio copia
dal vero copia più copy più impari
perché a scuola si copia per imparare il
vero segreto di lonardo e che per
diventare una provincia bisogna copiare
copiare non è brutto vuol dire imparare
lo facciamo da me mini da galante ce lo
siamo scordati
il bello di lonardo che non se l'è mai
scordato e per tutta la vita ha cercato
di copiare imparare torniamo a questi 50
soggetti dentro un unico foglio di quei
6 mila qui dentro ci sono macchine e
robot che noi ci siamo divertiti di
costruire li portiamo in giro per il
mostro nelle nostre mostre questo per
esempio il leone meccanico
questo è uno dei pochissimi oggetti che
leonardo ha realizzato questo è
storicamente è stato costruito da
leonardo noi abbiamo interpretato in
questo modo perché per fare l'ingegnere
ha come fossero a teatro
l'ha regalato re di francia ha pagato
dai fiorentini era un meccanismo che ha
destato meraviglia
nel 1500 un uomo che può costruire una
specie di oggetto che sembra un leone
provate a immaginarlo con la pelle di un
leone sopra camminare anche per 2 metri
e la magia nel 1500 libellula meccanica
guardatela bene questo è l'antenato del
drone oggi tutti altro nel dronero
questo è il drone di leonardo vinci a
quattro ali due motori non è fatto per
gli esseri umani che sono due motori a
molla questa per esempio è l'evoluzione
l'abbiamo costruito dieci anni fa del
sotto del detenga del carro armato che
in realtà leonardo sapeva non funzionare
la venduto al duca il duca si è fatto
due già tela pagato ma poi leonardo
sapeva che quella macchina non avrebbe
funzionato si è costruito inventandosi
lui il vero carro armato che è marino e
quindi sull'acqua può galleggiare ma se
detenuti per lui così questi oggetti
questo è uno strumento musicale pazzesco
e un pianoforte ma in realtà dentro c'è
un violino perché lui studiava più
studiare più studiare vuole copiare più
cose studi più cose copie in più ne puoi
mettere insieme ottenere una terza cosa
l'inventore con il quale conosce tante
cose riesca a mettere due o tre insieme
per ottenere una terza cosa
leonardo più conosceva chi sapeva che
poteva inventare in queste postazioni
multimediali che abbiamo nostro mostra
milano si vedono per la prima volta i
veri codice da vinci
avete mai visto un codice da vinci
eccolo qua è un libricino piccolo non è
come il codice atlantico di pompei leoni
questo è il vero codice da vinci
leonardo si portava questi libricini da
passeggio in tasca nella borsa e andava
a osservare la natura come oggi facciamo
noi stupidamente col cellulare facciamo
la foto ce la siamo dimenticati noi a
lui passava ore a studiare la natura la
sua fonte d'ispirazione era la natura in
questi taccuini c'è anche lui che
studiava gli antichi greci romani non è
vero che ra ignorante anzi dentro solo
questo manoscritto ci sono circa 500
oggetti mai visti prima
e tutto nasce dalla prima pagina che
l'ultima di questo manoscritto dove lui
osserva la natura questa è la libellula
che lui disegna vi ricordate la macchina
di prima la fa diventare poi meccanica
ma prima devi studiare la natura da di
osservarla appassionarti studiare i
greci gli antichi romani per costruire
per esempio questa
questa è una delle tante macchine
fino ad ora non hanno fatto la macchina
volante ne ha fatte tante quanti sono
gli animali che sono in grado di volare
questo per esempio è l'aquila meccanica
l'abbiamo costruita in scala 1 a 1 è
presente a milano piazza scala sono
dodici metri di apertura alare e notate
che ci sono tanti sportellini non è che
lo rotta e che anche un bambino sa che
io non posso mettere una la una tela e
fare così non funzionerà mai
leonardo non era stupido sapeva che per
inventare delle macchine deve osservare
copiare la natura quindi l'aquila che
cosa per volare alle piume quelle sono
le piume meccaniche perché così facendo
la la quando si abbassa schiaccia l'area
quando si alza l'aria passa attraverso
le piume tutto questo
e arriviamo una cosa strana come si fa
applicare questa mia ricerca all'arte
possibile che qua dentro ci sono delle
cose da dire
eppure si la ricerca sulle macchine che
stiamo facendo è enorme non finirà mai
sono 6 mila manoscritti la cosa un po
strana che abbiamo cominciato a
osservare l'arte da un punto di vista
che cos'è questo oggetto che vedete
sullo sfondo è l'ultima cena di leonardo
vinci più famoso quadro cattolico
cristiano presente praticamente in tutte
le chiese del mondo
sicuramente a casa avete un libro dove
c'è questo oggetto ma questo oggetto è
di leonardo vinci sì però c'è un
problema oggi si chi ha la fortuna di
andare a trovarlo ma potete anche
guardare sui libri ba in questo luogo
che il refettorio di santa maria delle
grazie bianco spoglio in fondo c'è
questa parete di 8 metri per sei
dove c'è una crosta sapete cosa dire
croste non l'ho detto io 1800 bossi
scrive quella larva di di pinto che non
è più di leonardo vinci perché leo nodo
vincere uno sperimentatore osservava
voleva fare cose nuove usava la
tecnologia più avanzata dell'epoca per
creare per esempio un dipinto ad olio su
un muro non si poteva fare perché poi
cosa è successo dopo un anno e
cominciato a staccarsi dalla parete
perché usano i colori grassi
questo vuol dire che però all'epoca
quando lui ha finito l'ultima cena i
colori erano vivi come quella della dama
dell'ermellino
era un rosso vivo talmente meravigliose
che copisti sono subito accorsi a
copiare quest'opera d'arte meravigliosa
ma che subito si ed erto realtà si è
distrutta nel 1700 1800 l'anno ridipinta
poi nel 1999 l'anno scrostata ma di
leonardo non è rimasto più niente
quello che sia rimasto veramente una
cosa che qui si vergognerebbe anche lo
stesso leonardo nel 1497 la situazione
era molto diversa
grazie alla tecnologia la ricerca
filologia macchina le si dice nera
andare a vedere esattamente cosa c'era
all'epoca e cosa doveva essere le cose
noi abbiamo ricostruito virtualmente
perché l'originale è meglio non toccarlo
usando la tecnologia digitale abbiamo
ridipinto l'ultima cena in modo da farvi
vedere adesso come era l'ultima cena nel
1500 che era cosa molto diversa
intanto guardate qua l'ottanta per cento
non esiste più e quel poco che rimane
oggi è un colore sbiadito
noi abbiamo preso tutte le copie fatte
nei dieci anni successivi è come se oggi
facessimo le fotografie all'epoca si
chiamano i copisti copisti copiavano da
lì abbiamo trovato in colori veri le
forme e abbiamo fatto un processo
digitale per cui abbiamo ricostruito
ultima cena così come doveva apparire
nel 1500 scoprendo che una cosa molto
divertente bella
intanto abbiamo utilizzato gli stessi
disegni di leonardo sovrapposti al
dipinto abbiamo potuto ricostruire le
parti mancanti quel famoso braccio con
quel coltello che molti hanno scritto
libri del suo sacco di fesserie i mostri
fantasmi che ci sono né l'ultima cena
cose assurde perché forse non c'è tempo
di studiarle pure quello e pietro e
perché ha un coltello non è un assassino
perché pietro deve essere l'uomo col
coltello pensile riconoscibile
avete presente la sorella di della di
giovanni che forse assomiglia a una
donna al lado problema non è la domanda
non è che assomiglio è una donna
assomigliano da una marchi lonardo
doveva farlo così per sempre
riconoscibile
allora non importava fare una donna un
uomo era la riconoscibilità dei
personaggi erano a teatro
oggi possiamo vedere che leonardo ha
ricostruito è dipinto anche le tre
lunette superiori il boss fondo blu
azzurro lapislazzulo con delle stelline
dorate
la cosa incredibile l'avete de qua e che
leonardo ha realizzato anche 33 metri di
soffitto l'ultima cena non è quel
rettangolo che vedete suoi sul libro c'è
anche sopra lunette continua ancora
perché leonardo ha fatto una specie di
opera tridimensionale ha creato un'opera
avvolgente quadrimensionale perché poi
quando arrivava la luce è una meraviglia
del per gli occhi qui siamo in un
refettorio lì si mangiava la cosa
meravigliosa e mangiare alzare lo
sguardo a vedere il cielo stellato in
fondo la vedete l'ultima cena restaurata
digitalmente era un tutt'uno
tridimensionale con le volte
leonardo ha inventato la realtà virtuale
ha inventato il cinema
lì dentro non eravamo davanti a un
quadro piatto ma eravamo veramente uno
spettacolo tridimensionale perché
guardate a destra ea sinistra ci sono
gli arazzi che continuano poi nel
dipinto la prospettiva è tale per cui è
come se io disegnarsi una stanza dentro
una stanza per cui ho creato un ambiente
virtuale dove io sto mangiando con gesù
è una cosa meravigliosa
vi lascio vedere un piccolo video adesso
ve lo commento
siamo nel refettorio abbiamo ricostruito
completamente tardi e oggi si può vedere
la nostra mostra con gli occhi luz
virtualmente uno spettacolo meraviglioso
bisogna utilizza la tecnologia moderna
per fare delle macchine del tempo per
poter andare a vedere le opere così come
erano nel 1500 è uno spettacolo
meraviglioso provate a immaginare la
sera quando cambiamo alla luce altro
l'oggetto spoglio che abbiamo oggi e
notate per esempio che ad esse si sta ci
sono dei tavoli di legno quei tavoli in
legno che lui ha dipinto non sono del
gesù storico dell'anno zero dettata di
noi
gesù non aveva negli occhi azzurri se
era biondo e soprattutto mangiava per
terra perché era proprio di un'altra
parrocchia
in realtà l'ultima cena è stata
disegnata come fanno tutti gli autori
ambientandolo in un luogo che era la
milano del 1500 quindi quel tavolo dove
non c'è santo bravo
[Musica]
e il tavolo del refettorio dove i frati
mangiavano quindi non solo alla stanza
virtuale ma sto mangiando le stesse cose
che mangia a gesù perché questo né
quella tavola ci sono i pani
pesci e altre cose che allo stesso modo
più denaro ma guardate per esempio i
piatti un piatto blu che altrove un
piatto
verso dei vestiti quindi vuol dire che i
piatti sono di metallo e guarda caso nel
1500 a milano cesaroni piatti di pentro
tutto torna
usando la logica e la ricerca
scientifica si può ricostruire uno
spettacolo che nessuno ha mai visto oggi
noi siamo in grado di entrare rientro
con i caschi virtuali che devono essere
utilizzati non solo per i videogiochi ma
anche per la ricerca storica scientifica
è uno spettacolo meraviglioso
avvicinarsi poter vedere cose che
nessuno ha mai visto come il sale che
cade le gambe i piedi di gesù che poi
sono stati distrutti da una porticina di
racconti ce ne sono meravigliosi trucchi
che utilizzava leonardo
noi cerchiamo col nostro lavoro di tirar
fuori le macchine di leonardo ma
soprattutto di raccontare ai bambini che
mameli siete anche voi chi ha voglia di
imparare e un bambino
i trucchi che utilizzava leonardo che ha
imparato dal verrocchio venetico solo
una per fare i personaggi mi ha
utilizzato la tecnica della candela
metto un personaggio in posa davanti a
un muro davanti metto una candela mi
proietta l'ombra io posso tracciare la
silhouette e dell'ombra e mezzo lavoro
di proporzioni e già fatto per non
parlare del buco che c'è nella tempia di
gesù perché c'è un buco nella tempi di
gesù cioè sono andata da una santa maria
grazia c'è perché lì ci attaccava il
laser del 1500 delle cornici né che mi
aiutano per fare la prospettiva della
stanza
insomma leonardo a vinci è assolutamente
io lo chiamo leonardo in c2 ci presenta
un nuovo leonardo a vinci si fa capire
come per diventare una da vinci bisogna
studiare copiare dalla mattina alla sera
vedere un capolavoro come l'ultima cena
ci può lasciare magari straniti diciamo
ci riusciremo mai no ma se impariamo i
suoi trucchi e sappiamo che lui di per
arrivare l'ultima cena ha disegnato
mille disegni anche brutti ce lo rende
più umano
per non parlare degli errori di leonardo
vi voglio lasciare con questa immagine
finale è interessante perché tanto c'è
il cubo magico e per scoprire cosa c'è
dentro dovete pensarci
le luci sono delle candele leonardo
viveva nel 1500 i bambini oggi neanche
se lo immagino cosa vuol dire vivere nel
1500 altro che computer wikipedia
televisione 0 informazione informazioni
deve andarsela a cercare nelle
biblioteche altro che leonardo lo ha
fatto e ha faticato per avere un libro
per poter studiare
noi abbiamo la possibilità facendo così
di avere mille libri eppure non
eleggiamo neanche uno
allora il mio invito è intanto il
segreto di nardò avete capito studiare
copiare e imparare sempre cose nuove che
utilissimo osservare la natura come
fonte d'ispirazione e altri 99 segreti
che oggi non vi racconto perché me li
voglio tenere per me ma vi voglio
invitare da domani a un giorno alla
settimana soprattutto per i vostri figli
a spegnere il cellulare e mettersi nei
panni di leonardo nel 1500 vero
elettricità solo libricino e
osservazione della natura per tirare per
spegnere il cellulare i vostri whatsapp
i vostri quasi cose che non ci aiutano a
diventar leonardo vinci accendere
da vinci che in voi grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]